what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today Ryan Reynolds
has recently opened up about how he
feels about announcing that Deadpool 3
is well underway and Hugh Jackman is
returning as Wolverine now of course all
of us fans are crazy excited we were all
freaking out and we couldn't believe the
news not only is Hugh Jackman returning
as Wolverine the Wolverine but he is now
going to be in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe interacting with hopefully some
of our favorite characters and of course
this is the type of news that breaks the
internet and that is exactly what it did
when Ryan Reynolds released that video
announcing Hugh Jackman is going to be
coming back as Wolverine everybody
freaked out and now Ryan Reynolds has
opened up in an interview with Forbes
talking about how exactly it felt to
break the internet with that amazing
news and he actually goes on to talk
about how this really wouldn't be
possible without the fans in fact
Deadpool 1 was only made because of the
fans but of course we're going to dive
into all of this we'll go over the whole
entire interview and talk about how
excited Ryan Reynolds is for Deadpool 3
and his reaction to basically the fans
reacting to the huge news so if you love
Marvel content be sure to subscribe to
the channel and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and MCU news so as I
mentioned this interview is with Forbes
they were speaking to Ryan Reynolds
about Hugh Jackman returning as
Wolverine in Deadpool 3 the announcement
videos that he released and subsequently
how they blew up the internet now I'm
assuming pretty much everybody has seen
these videos I would be shocked if you
haven't but if you haven't for some
reason no judgment at all but here they
are right now in case you haven't seen
them and if you already have well enjoy
them again
I have nothing
here
just completely
empty up here
and terrifying but we did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure
hi hi
how are you you have questions yes I I
had a lot of questions I'm sure you had
a lot of questions but rest assured
we're going to answer them right now
like for example how is Wolverine alive
yeah after Logan Logan takes place in
2029 a totally separate thing Logan died
in Logan not touching that
what actually happens in our film
is those are just brief Recaps if you
want to watch the full videos you can
find them on Ryan reynolds's YouTube
channel and kind of anywhere on the
internet but in this interview with
Forbes he talked about how excited he
was and how he's actually been sitting
on those videos for a few weeks now
here's what he said I couldn't be more
excited I mean especially to do it this
way ultimately I get to work with some
of my closest friends in the world and
that doesn't happen every day working in
this business I'm thrilled and I've been
sitting on those couple of teasers for a
few weeks now it's one of those moments
where you're hitting send or a tweet or
a post your hand is shaking when you're
messing with the Zeitgeist in a way like
that it's been amazing now right away I
just want to talk about how nervous Ryan
Reynolds was to announce this to the
world when he especially knows how big
this is that's just so great to me he
knows what he's about to do he knows
he's about to give so many fans who love
Deadpool and Wolverine all that they
want Wolverine returning but Hugh
Jackman returning as Wolverine all we've
really been talking about recently is
who is Marvel Studios going to get to
play the new Wolverine we never really
thought that Hugh Jackman would return
that was never really on the table for
us Hugh Jackman stated many times that
Wolverine was done for him he said
goodbye to that character so we didn't
think that he would be returning but
like Ryan Reynolds mentions in this
article he is now working with some of
his best closest friends and of course
that is Hugh Jackman so I love that Ryan
Reynolds was nervous because he is a fan
too he does this because he loves it
himself and he goes on to talk about
that in the article he says I feel the
same way that the fans do though I feel
as excited that this character is coming
back for another ride particularly in
this context I think it's something that
people have wanted for a long time to
get this pairing up on the big screen
and that's what we aim to do well they
aimed for it and they have hit their
target right on the mark because fans
have already lost their minds just by
watching Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds
sit on a couch together talking about
what is going to happen teasing us and
quite honestly I kind of hope that
Deadpool 3 is US basically just watching
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman be
themselves on screen you know kind of
just watching their friendship play out
on screen which is kind of what I'm
expecting in all honesty and one thing I
actually am expecting from this movie is
fan service now sometimes fan service
can be bad if executed poorly however I
have full faith in Ryan Reynolds each of
the Deadpool films did not disappoint we
haven't had a bad one yet and again I
must state that we do not acknowledge
the existence of Deadpool in the X-Men
Origins Wolverine film so ignoring that
we have not had a solo Deadpool film
that has been bad yet and Ryan Reynolds
has taken years to write this script for
Deadpool 3 so you know it's going to be
pretty dang near perfect if not perfect
and he goes on to talk about in this
interview how Deadpool wouldn't really
be possible without the fans he says I
think audiences really genuinely
appreciate having some authorship over
stories that are being told and why
stories are being told I for one can say
that Deadpool 1 never would have been
made if it wasn't for the outpouring of
demand from audiences across all social
media platforms and that's quite
legitimately what got the movie
greenlighted and before we finish what
he said in the interview I just want to
say I love this so much I love that Ryan
Reynolds appreciates the Deadpool fans
and he listens to them which is why I
think there is going to be some good fan
service in Deadpool 3. and if anything
it's going to be hilarious because of
course we know how Ryan Reynolds is
especially as Deadpool which is kind of
essentially himself but he finishes the
interview by actually stating that the
audience is the real boss the fans are
the real bosses he says there's
authorship there they feel some
authorship and ownership over that
Triumph so I think that's always
important to never forget who the real
boss is the real boss is the folks at
home and the folks going to the cinema
to pay their way in and that also really
is quite applicable to so many other
aspects of the business that we have at
maximum effort and certainly at FUBU TV
I love this I love Ryan Reynolds I love
his attitude about everything and I love
how he announced that Wolverine was
going to be in Deadpool 3. he did it so
casually with Hugh Jackman just in the
background randomly going yeah sure why
not Ryan but then of course he followed
it up with the two of them being super
excited to actually talk about it
because some people were thinking that
well maybe they're just trolling but the
next video showed us they weren't now
I've already heard fans talking about
when to expect a trailer for Deadpool 3
and I'm sorry to say we are so far away
from that Deadpool 3 does not hit
theaters until September 6th of 2024.
that's just about two years away so do
not expect a trailer anytime soon even
though Ryan Reynolds has of course been
teasing us with these little videos they
haven't even begun to film Deadpool 3
yet Ant-Man and the WASP is five months
away and we haven't even gotten the
trailer for it yet so don't expect any
official footage from Deadpool 3 sadly
anytime soon but you never know with
Ryan Reynolds he could come out and give
us another video like he's done the past
two he could even introduce other
characters that are going to be in the
movie in the same exact way he did with
Hugh one thing that is for sure is that
this is certainly going to be an
exciting Road leading up to Deadpool 3
and I'm sure Deadpool 3 is going to be
absolutely amazing so let me know your
thoughts about what Ryan Reynolds had to
say in this interview in the comments
down below and I'd also love to hear
what you want from the story of Deadpool
3 what do you think it should be about
leave your thoughts Down Below in the
comments don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest MCU news for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof
foreign